their focus baby focus train I like
happy when I'm tired on goofy and
ridiculous what I'm well-rested I'm
tired and goofy all right now I'm
ridiculous the point beings are
ridiculous always hi I'm Dan Seibert I'm
Ryan right you want to reverse that so
yeah I'm not the [ __ ] no it's okay
we're gonna watch a show today for call
of duty advanced warfare the multiplayer
reveal trailer yeah let's see how I'm
going to get murdered yeah over let's
see this people who are exceptionally
better than me who I will see at parties
can I say something before we start this
with a quick is Modern Warfare 2 call of
duty I loved it that was actually decent
at it and then suddenly people started
making that their life goal to be good
at call of duty I just want to go online
and get destroyed the second you like
jack in yeah sometimes I have like a
game was like yes this is evenly matched
but like 9 times out of 10 I'm with like
the people that play it for like 6 hours
a day yeah I still have fun with this
yeah let's just watch our do suck see oh
come on
oh [ __ ] me right okay
nice Jesus hahaha I'm never going to be
able to keep up with this guy oh my god
bread whoa what is that thing you just
launched a missile
yeah it's killstreaks bro oh come it's
so cool I've Austin never fully play
call of duty - that looks great
oh [ __ ]
Wow whoa whoa whoa what do you do oh
dude no way is some of the good [ __ ] I
have ever seen dude this this looks like
so much fun yeah you're good okay
ah good you know this is kind of feeling
Heil eleska now yeah I might be about a
whole mile okay well I can't sure
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] a man this is some of
the coolest [ __ ] ever
I love these players they just run
through the city murder yeah
oh hi it's [ __ ] goldmine
pre-order the call duty advanced warfare
day zero edition to get 24-hour early
access double XP to custom weapons in
the advanced arsenal one of the kill
streaks is the gold mag hagel that I was
[ __ ] they're gonna eyes awesome yeah I
[ __ ] love golden it yeah but it
literally is a space listen what mythic
killstreaks is this
yeah I'm not I never I've only played
like a few times I just remember getting
my ego crushed at parties yeah I've
never seen that before and if I had seen
that before
missiles able to murder people that yeah
use I would I would've bought this game
a long time ago this is perhaps the most
unique multiplayer I've seen from call
of duty in like six iterations because
before it's been pretty standards like
you know just like basic soldier
movement yeah yeah like every now and
then they slight like change this really
changes a lot yeah that's what it makes
it halo less so this feels like a little
future it's futuristic yeah yeah yeah
it's like that [ __ ] that would not have
in real life yeah I mean it's still got
the fast pace in this of Call of Duty
which like give and take for me like I
love it sometimes sometimes it's what
ends up getting it killed
secondly there's just something about
the movement that's different from Halo
though um because like at least a before
the multiplayer was a little bit more
like you know like you feel like you
weigh something this looks like with all
the exoskeletons you're like running
like the yeah I'm a commander whatever
Wow just day to myself with that I like
what I'm seeing Dan I can honestly tell
you I like what I'm seeing okay
I approve all right of what they're
going fed okay alright before it was
just like I really want to play this so
I can see Kevin Spacey now it's like
know for sure I want to do it for the
game play - yeah Dan this game has Ryan
rides approval like I'm expecting
destiny to be my jam for a long time but
I do think I could log I'm gonna ask a
couple days game oh I'm sorry do do you
remember last time we played halo
together and no I will train and I will
ask [ __ ] you okay
rim job YouTube please just for you okay
just for point my gay I just do
or you could just like I don't know buy
me a beer yeah buy you a beer suck your
dick the song oh hey murder you and
[ __ ] Khan huh not gay just doing its
brew for sure anyway guys if you hit the
channel you can subscribe hey you watch
bad and you can subscribe to dance
gaming channel that's Sibert channel so
uh dan it's that time mm-hmm we shout
some [ __ ] up go Alex white fire
fast last name that's a good some clever
name that you came up with there my
friend Ryan Jerry Sally and more sorry
there's a lot of you well you're all
beasts please give me a shoutout
we're beasts you hear that and I'm war I
represent all the more you're part of
the more okay that's really cool there's
a lot of beast uh you are you're a beast
man you're like [ __ ] you're like Hank
McCoy that's what you are like a martial
witch yeah yeah you're like [ __ ] the
beauty in the end of [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is the Beast and real name Adam Adam
Adam what Adam beastmode that's what you
that's what you are Nick window all I
can say is you guys are really awesome
and you just earned yourself a sub
please shout out okay Nick we don't know
me please
shout out Scooby Doo you're awesome
thanks for subbing to the channel man
you know what we do work to earn our
subscribers mm-hmm this is hard work I
sit my butt hurts like a lot right my
back is in minor pain from sitting about
50% of our earnings have to go to
chiropractors stuff I'm seeing a doctor
right now it's it's pretty bad cortisone
shots every day I do steroids
well I'm not nasal steroid oh don't take
him out and if your name's Nick Rimes a
big dick dad Mary uh dan wait Mary oh
that's a yeah Dean near you brothers
that's a you say dude a Ryan and Co
Benny just wanted you guys to know I'm a
fan of your bids and watch him in my
small country New Zealand hey Leland
anyway keep up the funny vids man and it
would be hilariously cool if you gave me
a shout-out ha ha there's a lot of
pressure to be hilarious huh oh man I
just turn on the switch what's the
switch you know you were funny yeah I
did I do feel more funny mm-hmm joke
Kevin you can't get the joke outright
cuz it's it's too funny buddy it's a
joke
yeah ok you can't save the joke because
it's too funny you guys do funny too
funny too funny too funny this is too
funny too funny damn Mario you you son
of a [ __ ] you